Sabemos que "y" es directamente proporcional a "x".
Si "y" es igual a 30 cuando "x" es igual a "6"
determina el valor de "x" cuando "y" es igual a 45.
¡Wow! esta es mucha información,
vamos poco a poco.
Déjame empezar con esto,
con "y" es directamente proporcional a "x",
que "y" sea directamente proporcional a "x"
en símbolos,
simplemente quiere decir que "y",
lo podemos escribir como "k",
por "x", donde "k" es una constante,
donde "k" es un número,
entonces sería bueno
poder conocer este número.
Vamos a seguir, a ver si podemos tener información,
que nos permita obtenerlo.
Entonces dice,
si "y"es igual a 30
cuando "x" es igual a 6,
esto suena a información nueva,
entonces sabemos que "y" es igual a 30
cuando "x" es igual a 6.
Vamos a poner esto
en la igualdad que tenemos aquí,
entonces "y" vale 30,
cuando "x" es igual a 6.
Pero esta constante sigue aquí verdad,
sigue siendo "k" por 6.
Ok,
entonces esto está muy padre,
tenemos que 30 es igual a "k" por 6,
entonces aquí ya podemos despejar "k".
¿Cómo le hacemos para despejar "k"?
pues vamos a dividir entre 6
ambos lados de la de la igualdad,
aquí entre 6...
entre 6...
de este lado también entre 6.
El chiste es que estos 6 se cancelan,
y por lo tanto,
nos queda que "k" es igual a 30 entre 6,
5 es igual a "k",
p lo que es lo mismo, "k" es igual a 5.
Entonces esto está súper bien,
la información que nos da esta parte del problema
es que "y" no sólo es una constante por "x",
sino que sabemos exactamente quién es esa constante que "y" es igual a 5 veces "x".
Muy bien,
entonces vamos a la última parte del .problema
Dice, determina el valor de "x"
cuando "y" es igual a 45,
cuando "y" es igual a 45...
entonces ahora debemos de poner aquí que
"y"vale 45
entonces tendríamos 45
es igual a "5x"
y justo lo que nos piden determinar,
es el valor de "x",
pero ya está fácil encontrar el valor de "x" aquí,
simplemente dividimos entre 5 ambos lados de la igualdad,
entre 5, entre 5,
estos se cancelan
y de este modo nos queda...
nos queda que 45 entre 5 o sea 9,
es igual a "x".
9 es igual a equis
y para que se vea un poco más bonito,
déjame escribirlo como "x" es igual a 9.
Muy bien, entonces terminamos,
con la información que nos dan,
pudimos concluir que "x" es igual a 9.